denim a brand new way to write
server-side JavaScript it solves many of
the same problems as nodejs and was even
created by the same guy like node it
uses the v8 JavaScript engine under the
hood but the rest of the runtime is
implemented in rust and typescript our
journey into denna land begins in a
single type script file in this file we
have access to all the types in the
runtime which means we can write
strongly typed code and get
documentation and intellisense directly
in the IDE without ever needing to touch
a TS config file the features in the
runtime can be accessed from this demo
namespace let's console.log the current
working directory of the filesystem we
can execute our script with demo run
from the command line but you'll notice
the throws an error and that's because
demo is secure by default you the
developer need to give permission to
perform different actions in the runtime
in this case we can use the allow read
flag to allow this operation security is
great but my favorite thing is how
everything asynchronous is promise based
we can make a network request using the
fetch API just like we would in the
browser and because it supports
top-level wait we don't even need an
async function here we can start
resolving promises without any extra
boilerplate code denno attempts to make
your code as browser compatible as
possible it contains a window object
with lifecycle events that you can
listen to allowing developers to more
easily write code that can interrupt
between browsers and servers not to
mention it can also execute web assembly
binaries but one thing that won't work
in demo are your NPM packages instead
you import packages using the modern yes
module syntax with remote modules being
referenced by their URL when you run
your script for the first time it will
download this code locally and cache it
there's no package JSON and code can be
referenced from any URL very similar to
how things work in the browser demo
provides a set of standard modules to
solve common use cases for example we
can import serve from the HTTP module we
can use it to create a server that's
treated as an async iterable we can then
await every request from the server and
respond to it accordingly and that's an
awesome starting point for a server-side
JavaScript app now then au 1.0 just hit
release candidate 1 so if you start
using it today
consider yourself an early adopter do
you think denno is the future of
server-side JavaScript let me know in
the comments below thanks for watching
hit the like button and I will see you
in the next one